Since days are represented on the horizontal axis on this graph, what this
question is really asking is what vertical coordinate goes with the horizontal
coordinate of 7 on this graph. So we start by counting over 7 horizontally, and
then moving up to find the point on the graph that has a horizontal coordinate
of 7. Then we just need to see what vertical coordinate this corresponds to.
This is right above the line representing 160 for n, so that means the answer
must be 161. Remember to be super careful about which axis represents which
variable. What's even more interesting is comparing this to our equation. If we
let d equal 7 here, or just substitute in 7 for d, and then solve for n, we get
161, which is exactly the point that we found on the graph. The equation and the
graph are just different ways of describing the same thing, so of course, they
have to agree.